let's try to come up with a
mathematically rigorous definition for
what this statement means the statement
that the limit of f of X as X approaches
C is equal to L so let's say that this
means that you can get you can get f of
X as close as close to L as you want as
you want I'll put that in quotes right
over here because it's kind of a little
loosey goosey is how close is that but
as close as you want by getting getting
X sufficiently close sufficient ly close
close to C so another way of saying this
is if you tell me hey I want to get my f
of X to be within 0.5 of this limit then
you're telling me if this limit is
actually true you should be able to hand
me a value around see that if X isn't
within that range that f of X is
definitely going to be as close to L as
I desire so let me draw that out to make
it a little bit clearer and I'm going to
zoom in I'll you draw another diagram so
let's say that let's say that is my
drawing this right over here is my
y-axis and I'm going to zoom in I'm
going to draw a slightly different
function just so we can really focus on
what's going on around here the range is
around C and the range is around L so
that's X this right over here is y let's
say that this is this is C and let's say
let's just zoom in on our function so
let's say our function looks is doing
something like let's say it does
something like let's say I want it to be
defined at C at least just for the it
could be you can always find a limit
even where it is defined but let's say
our function looks something like that
and it can even have a little kink in it
the way I drew it so it looks something
like this it's undefined let me draw it
a little bit different let me draw it a
little bit different so it is undefined
when X is equal to C so this is the
point where there is a hole it is
undefined when
X is equal to C and it even has a little
kink in it just like that and we want to
do is prove that the limit as X the
limit of f of X and let me make it clear
this is the graph of y is equal to f of
X we want to get an idea for what this
definition is saying if we're claiming
that the limit of f of X as X approaches
C is L so conceptually we get the gist
already we already get the gist that
this right over here is L but what is
this definition saying what's saying
that you can get as can get f of X as
close to L as you want as you want so if
you tell someone I want to get within a
certain I want to get f of X within a
certain range of L then if this limit is
actually true if the limit of f of X if
the limit of f of X as X approaches C
really is equal to L then they should be
able to find a range around C that if as
long as X is around that range your f of
X is going to be in the range that you
want so let me actually go through that
exercise it really is a little bit like
a game so someone comes up to you and
says well ok I don't necessarily believe
that that you're claiming that the limit
of f of X as X approaches C is equal to
L I'm not really sure if that's the case
but I agree with this definition so I'm
going to I want to get within I want to
get within 0.5 I want to get f of X
within 0.5 of L so this right over here
this right over here would be L plus 0.5
and this right over here is L L minus
0.5 and then you say fine
I'm going to give you a range around see
that if you take any X within that range
your f of X is always going to fall in
this range that you care about and so
you look at this and obviously we
haven't explicitly defined this function
but you can even eyeball it the way this
function is defined it won't be that
easy for all functions but you look at
it like this and you say that this value
just the way it's drawn right over here
let's say that this is
see minus 0.25 and let's say that this
value right over here is C plus 0.25 C
plus 0.25 and so you tell them look as
long as you get X within 0.25 of C so as
long as your X's are sitting someplace
over here the corresponding f of X the
corresponding f of X is going to sit in
the range that you care about and you're
saying okay that fine the you won that
round let me make it even tighter maybe
with instead of saying within 0.5 I want
to get within zero 0.05 and then you'd
have to do this exercise again and find
another range and in order for this to
be true in order for this to be true you
have to be able to do this for any range
for any range that they give you for any
range around L that they give you you
have to be able to get f of X within
that range by finding a range around see
that as long as X is that range around C
f of X is going to sit within that range
so I'll let you think about that a
little bit there's a lot to think about
but hopefully this made sense we did it
for the particular example of someone
hands you the 0.5 I want F of X within
0.5 of L and you say well as long as X
is within point two-five of C you're
going to match it you need to be able to
do that for any range they give you
around
L and then this limit will definitely be
true so in the next video we will now
generalize that and that will really
bring us to the famous epsilon-delta
definition of limits